[Musica]
[Applauso]
liberté égalité fraternité
chi è che non si emoziona di fronte al
motto della rivoluzione francese
eppure eppure a me qualcosa è sempre
stonato e quel concetto di fraternità
che mi stona un po mi sono sempre
chiesta perché non parlare di soffrite
sta bene no liberté egalité sopra di te
e quindi di questo stasera voglio
parlarvi e lo faccio dedicando questo
pensiero a madame all on the gosh che
proprio negli anni della rivoluzione
francese nel 1791 pubblicava la
dichiarazione universale dei diritti
delle donne e delle cittadine e diceva
una cosa molto semplice se le donne
hanno diritto di salire sul patibolo
perché non sulla tribuna e purtroppo nel
lei è salita sul patibolo è stata
ghigliottinata perché si era immischiata
nelle cose della repubblica
a me è andata molto bene sono sulla
tribuna quindi ma lo devo anche a lei e
lei è una delle tante sorelle che potrei
ricordare questa sera persone che si
sono battute nel corso dei secoli per i
diritti delle donne ma più in generale a
me piace dire sorelle che si sono
battute per una maggiore civiltà nelle
nostre società e quindi parliamo di
sorellanza
cito un'altra grande pensatrice francese
simone de beauvoir
parafrasando un suo modo di dire
posso dire che sorelle non si nasce si
diventa
e quindi vi voglio raccontare come lo
sono diventata io ho cominciato da
piccola avevo 9 anni ed ero alta così
ero più alta di mia madre
ero più alta di mio padre ero più alta
soprattutto della mia maestra delle
elementari
inutile dirlo che mi sentivo un mostro e
allora beh cosa mi ha salvato mi ha
salvato la pallacanestro nella
pallacanestro ho scoperto che potevo
essere un mostro tra mostri o per meglio
dire che nella pallacanestro femminile
c'era il momento della rivalsa di noi
apparentemente mostri e che la
sorellanza tra quelle giovani donne tra
quelle bambine realtà avevamo nove anni
poteva effettivamente cambiare la nostra
vita
ho giocato a pallone a pallacanestro da
quando avevo 9 anni fino a quando non
avevo 32 poi ho smesso perché sono
svenuta dopo un'ultima partita quindi ho
capito che il mio corpo non ce la faceva
più e non so se l'avete mai notato ma in
realtà pallacanestro si gioca in cinque
come sono cinque le dita di una mano e
sul campo ci sono due piccole tre grandi
e io ho iniziato come la più alta e poi
ho cambiato tutti i ruoli e la mia vita
ho iniziato come pivot per chi conosce
la lo sport in questione o e ho finito
come play maker e questa esperienza mi
ha arricchito moltissimo perché non
soltanto mi ha aiutato a gestire le mie
relazioni con le mie sorelle ma
soprattutto mi ha fatto capire quanto
fosse complessa la strategia del vivere
insieme del condividere le scelte di
muoversi alunni
ci sono come le dita di una mano per
raggiungere un obiettivo
quindi questo è stato il mio primo
gradino di sorellanza e devo
sottolinearlo per me la sorellanza è uno
stato dell'anima e non ha nulla a che
vedere con il sesso biologico delle
persone di cui sto parlando si può
essere sorelle anche essendo di sesso
biologico maschile perché ripeto è un
modo di vivere le relazioni con le altre
persone
e allora il secondo gradino della mia
sorellanza avevo 18 anni
era il 1977 così vi ho detto anche la
mia età senza dirla
erano anni bui molto bui io vivevo a
roma
vivevo in una città in cui ogni sabato
c'erano degli scontri tra manifestanti e
polizia c'erano le famose p38 a pochi
passi della mia scuola fu ritrovato il
corpo
purtroppo esanime di dell'onorevole aldo
moro
erano anni bui molto bui e io ho trovato
la luce nel femminismo sono entrata un
giorno con una mia compagna di classe in
un luogo per me magico lo resterà tutta
la vita
via del governo vecchio per chi conosce
roma sa che lì c'era la casa occupata
dal movimento femminista romano e lì in
quello spazio neanche troppo agevole
ho scoperto una nuova forma di libertà è
una nuova forma di sorellanza quella che
noi vivevamo nei cosiddetti collettivi
di self help faceva andava di moda dirlo
così perché l'avevano inventata negli
stati uniti
in realtà erano dei gruppi di
autocoscienza in cui tra donne giovani e
meno giovani perché
lì ho scoperto anche la potenza del
dialogo intergenerazionale che cerco di
praticare da quel momento in poi adesso
sono io l'anziana e cerco di parlare con
i giovani che sono i miei studenti ho le
mie studentesse ma ripeto in quello
spazio in quel luogo per me magico ho
scoperto attraverso quei collettivi che
si poteva immaginare il mondo partendo
ovviamente da noi stessi il nostro detto
era il privato è politico
quindi se partiva da noi stesse
studiando i nostri corpi
parlando di sessualità facendo grande
battaglie per i diritti riproduttivi
marciando per le strade tutte insieme
urlando i nostri slogan con una potenza
e un'energia che non ho mai più
dimenticato l'energia che riescono a
sprigionare centinaia migliaia di donne
quando finalmente si ritrovano come
sorelle e non è scontato lo sappiamo non
è scontato quindi questo è stato il
grande successo della mia adolescenza
dall'infanzia all'adolescenza
poi gli studi i viaggi all'estero la
formazione confesso sono diventato un
economista e poi e poi 25 anni fa quindi
non sono nata così come economista ci
sono diventata ancora una volta sono
diventato un economista femminista che
ho trovato il modo di unire quella che è
la mia passione politica
la mia sorellanza in termini politici
con il mio mestiere
la mia professione e come l'ho fatto
bene sono entrate in contatto con una
serie di studiose principalmente
statunitensi ma non soltanto
statunitensi che avevano fondato
un'associazione che si chiamava e si
chiama tuttora international association
of feminist economics siamo in tutto il
mondo è nel nord come nel sud
ecco abbiamo un progetto molto ambizioso
rivoluzionario proprio come l'immagine
che comunque mi mi sono scelta come
fondo che a cambiare l'economia cambiare
il paradigma economico dominante perché
ma perché fondato su un'ipotesi
assolutamente inaccettabile quella
secondo la quale ogni agente economico è
un homo economicus non bisogna essere
latinisti per capire il senso di questa
ipotesi homo economicus cioè uomo bianco
occidentale benestante perché altrimenti
non avrebbe i mezzi da poter fare quelle
che la mia disciplina nella sua versione
dominante afferma essere o afferma che
possano essere delle scelte razionali
che poi alla fine coincidono sempre che
con o la massimizzazione del profitto
lama sezione con la massimizzazione del
benessere ma per chi per chi può
ovviamente e tutti gli altri non sono le
donne tutti gli altri
le persone che noi contiamo per la
strada i vulnerabili i meno abbienti gli
immigrati tutti gli altri si può parlare
al massimo nella mia disciplina di
eterogeneità e invece noi economista e
femministe facciamo della parola
diversità la vera risorsa su cui
costruire un paradigma economico
alternativo e lo facciamo in tanti campi
ovviamente qui stasera non vi posso
parlare di tutti i campi in cui noi
applichiamo le nostre teorie ma di
almeno 1 sicuramente vi voglio parlare
se non altro per non rimandarvi a caso
le curiosità di quello che facciamo e
parlo di lavoro il concetto che dai
padri fondatori della nostra disciplina
è stato identificato come ciò che dà
valore a tutte le merci
quindi parliamo di lavoro che cos'è il
lavoro per un economista femminista in
alternativa
vista diciamo così tradizionale
beh per spiegarvelo voglio citare un
altro libro l'avrete capito io amo molto
i libri ma che sono portato anche una
dietro un po anche come scaramanzia
ecco un libro che è stato pubblicato di
recente non tradotto in italiano quindi
non sto facendo la pubblicità a nessuno
ma che si pone nel titolo una domanda
molto semplice che cucinava la cena ad
adam smith non so se voi sapete chi era
adam smith ma ve lo dico e molto
rapidamente è un grandissimo filosofo
uno dei fondatori dell'economia politica
in quel di e timbra in edimburgo in
scozia dove lui insegnava appunto
filosofia ma dal suo scritto principale
la ricchezza delle nazioni quello non me
la sarei mai potuta portare dietro
perché sono cinque volumi è nata la
nostra disciplina
ecco che cucinava la cena adatta smetta
perché se qualcuno si prendeva cura di
lui e grazie a quella cura e grazie a
quella attenzione e grazie a quella
protezione che lui poteva scrivere i
suoi libri e andare a insegnare
all'università e la risposta la sapete
vero
poteva essere la mamma o la moglie o una
governante o una cuoca era chiaramente
una donna in realtà è stata la mamma
perché lui non si è mai sposato ed è
rimasto con la mamma
finché lei non è morta quindi qui si sta
parlando di lavoro che normalmente non
viene riconosciuto da un punto di vista
economico perché non è retribuito ed è
invisibile il lavoro invisibile delle
donne in ambito domestico quel lavoro
invisibile che noi vogliamo invece non
soltanto far emergere quantificare
valorizzare ma sul quale noi vogliamo
costruire un uomo modo
di guardare alle attività lavorative in
un bellissimo saggio pubblicato da due
tra le più grandi economisti e
femministe americane nel sifone julie
nelson si fa anche lì una semplicissima
domanda forlan o forma nei per amore o
per denaro
la mamma di ada smetta di cucinava
perché amava il denaro di ada smetto
perché lo amava punto interrogativo la
risposta è opposta per entrambi perché
in realtà si può lavorare per entrambe
le motivi questi motivi e non si può
discriminare una forma di lavoro
rispetto ad un'altra anzi al contrario
dovrebbe essere valorizzata a pari
livello calcolata nel nostro prodotto
interno lordo e quant'altro e allora con
questo semplice esempio arriva all'oggi
arrivo al co lead arrivò la crisi che
stiamo vivendo arrivo al log dow al
confinamento che forse speriamo tutti e
tutte qui di esserci lasciati alle
spalle
beh mai come questa crisi e questo
periodo che abbiamo vissuto ci ha
mostrato l'importanza del lavoro di cura
ripeto di quel lavoro che spesso è
invisibile
abbiamo parlato di lavoratori essenziali
abbiamo parlato appunto di tanti
mestieri che fino a qualche giorno prima
ignoravamo e che pure per noi sono stati
vitali a cominciare dalle commesse dei
nostri supermercati
ecco la cura questo è un altro pilastro
dell'economia femminista e allora cosa
fare
oggi cosa fare
ispirati da un concetto di sorellanza
che lo ripeto è uno stato dell'anima è
quello per citare ancora una volta da
smith ma questa volta una volta ben
nutrito ne possiamo parlare dal punto di
vista più teorico ed un altro dei suoi
scritti devo dire uno degli suoi scritti
che amo di più
che è la teoria dei sentimenti morali
ecco in quel bellissimo scritto lui si
parla di una morale di un'etica diversa
da quella a cui siamo abituati quella
basata sul profitto insomma tanto per
capirci
ed è la morale della simpatia simpa
tosta essere in sintonia con gli altri
e cosa vuol dire dal punto di vista di
un nuovo paradigma economico dal punto
di vista della sorellanza dal punto di
vista della via d'uscita dalla crisi in
cui siamo attualmente ma vuol dire fare
delle scelte non soltanto per
l'interesse proprio ma al contrario
ponendosi nei panni delle persone con
cui noi siamo in relazione quindi fare
delle scelte valutandone l'impatto sulle
altre persone sulle comunità con cui noi
ovviamente dialoghiamo in questo caso
come economisti o semplicemente ne
facciamo parte come cittadini e
cittadine ecco questo è il messaggio
della sorellanza della simpatia che noi
economisti ed economisti femministi e le
femministe perché ci sono anche gli
uomini tra di noi non ci sono soltanto
donne vogliono portare avanti in questa
precisa fase storica insomma
permettetemi di chiudere con uno slogan
sorelle di tutto il mondo unitevi
qui c'è una scelta importante da fare
bisogna salvare il mondo da noi stessi
ed a noi stesse
[Applauso]